Jollibee is a religion there's two
religions in the Philippines actually
like three we have Christianity we have
a few Muslims and jollibee is the third
I'm American I'll be on Team McDonald's
and I'll be trying geology for the first
time I'm Filipino American and I am Team
Jollibee I'll be representing McDonald's
today I was born and raised in the
Philippines moved here when I was 19
Jolley beat is everybody's ride-or-die
so Jollibee is a very popular filipino
fast-food chain obviously started in the
philippines but it's like becoming more
of like a global franchise I've never
had jollibee it's been like a long time
on my bucket list I've never even heard
it really until today yeah well you're
in for a treat oh my gosh it is a
full-on meal its casino egg and rice
garlic rice it looks more like to me
like a lunch or like a dinner because it
has like a side of me it has the rice
and the egg but this also looks really
delicious this is a sausage McMuffin
with egg it is one of McDonald's
breakfast staples it's like basically
just like a biscuit stuffed with like
ham egg and cheese and delicious it's
sort of a testament to American
efficiency it's an entire breakfast
packed into any package okay let's swap
this is like my first taste of dollar
days I'm like overall this seems a bit
more like a like a complete entree
sandwich does it's really good with the
garlic rice this is a good McMuffin the
muffin part is a little bit dry but what
what they expect the biscuit always has
a very unique mcdonald's taste to it so
when I go there I'm not expecting to eat
off then take food I'm just expecting to
eat McDonald's I'm not really a fan of
Egg McMuffins
in the first place so I would still go
with this this was pretty good I like
the format the presentation and then the
taste good at the end of the day I got
to go at the nick muffin it's more
compact it's better for Alma go for a
breakfast I would rather have something
that
like really quickly and this is just
like the perfect bite because in America
we eat breakfast in the car alright so
here we have the quarter pounder with
cheese and fries this is my go-to lunch
order at McDonald's and this one looks
really good check that out it looks best
ones I've seen so we have the burger
steak meal so it's basically the burger
patty that Jollibee uses with gravy
mushrooms and obviously rice it also
comes with extra gravy Filipinos love
gravy so like KFC in different places
with that have gravy as like a side
they'll serve it and like a freaking
pitcher okay like KFC and the hope
inside like unlimited gravy and you can
like get them in like a pitcher so you
can like pour them all over your rice
and go straight for the meat I want to
eat that bird it's a McDonald's quarter
pounder I like that it has double the
meat to quarter pounders when I go to
when I do go to set McDonald's this
gravy is bomb no wonder you have
pictures of us rolling crap I'm still
going for the McDonald's it's a balanced
diet got your vegetable here what you
got a pickle in there that's that's like
three servings I have mad respect for
the quarter pound of cheese but I think
what this in front of me I would just go
with this one for lunch yes oh is that
my favorite hell yes chicken McNuggets
girl girl this is to me like the holy
grail of like McDonald's yeah Moe's it
is the Jolly spaghetti with chicken joy
looking at it I don't feel like my brain
computes cuz you got it like a piece of
like fried chicken drumstick yeah I
think you also got like a plateful of
spaghetti and that's like a combo
together there carrots in that it's hot
dog this is a thing this is like a
combination that's actually made yes
I'll sometimes have this on my birthday
I feel like this will be a little bit
well of all the things I've tried so far
this one tastes the most like homemade
like I really did enjoy this this tastes
like something my mother would have made
this is Filipino spaghetti this is not
Italian spaghetti it's like very
sweet there's hot dogs this is the dish
I think Americans would enjoy because it
has a very familiar flavors try then
that gets in the gravy yes you know what
this is the winning combination okay
jollibee gravy if you're comparing these
two this doesn't really come like it's
not yeah it's not as diverse it doesn't
feel like a full meal I only use chicken
nuggets asides but this is something I
could eat for lunch
this is the Jollibee peach mango pie and
this is the McDonald's apple pie you
wanna treatise this breading is already
different it looks oh yeah right like
comparing the stuffing is still really
good like from my childhood that's
really sweet this one too is very Apple
II I need to take a bites like from it
so it's for me to compare it right like
my god yeah
crunchy yeah and like buttery yeah it's
just great it even has like little
chunks of mango and peach inside I
wasn't expecting that it looked like it
was just jelly filled yeah I'm
definitely going with the peach mango
pie too
how did you like that Omar as far as
fast food is concerned it already tastes
pretty good
the menu has a lot of variety I feel
like I'd actually sit down to eat it but
if I ever went back I definitely go for
the spaghetti I could totally see myself
going to Jollibee for that like
breakfast rice bowl and then also for
the gravy like I just want to go through
the drive-thru just to order like gravy
as a side and I would definitely head up
jollibee for desserts cuz that peach
mango pie was WOW this is why all
Filipinos are obsessed with Jollibee but
I will drive some McDonald's just for
the fries but anything else
Jollibee has my heart
[Music]